I'd like to take a moment to defend Andy
thank you been sure in his defense it's
really easy to justify storing your
model in your view because it's so easy
to do for version 1 of cat clicker he
didn't set up anything special to store
his data he just asked for the data out
of the view updated it and put it right
back but as we can see that did not
scale very well when his project got
much bigger the biggest issue with
Andy's code is that he stored his data
in the Dom or more generally he didn't
separate his view and his model with an
octopus in fact in his code the model
and the view were the exact same thing
and that's what got him into so much
trouble